au monde populiste le nouveau monde
populiste et c'est aux éditions du cerf
et c'est absolument à lire en ce moment
autre défenseur de l'état et sa personne
ne le contestera le général de gaulle
50e anniversaire de sa mort aujourd'hui
alors faut-il ressusciter le gaullisme
est bien j'attends vos réponses au point
de vue on en débat mais d'abord donc
cette question qu'on pose sur twitter
êtes vous soulagé par l'élection de joe
biden à la maison blanche sénat c'est à
rien n'y comprendre parce que depuis
plusieurs plusieurs jours on demande à
chaque fois est ce que vous deviez que
donald trump soit réélu majorité de non
est ce que trump a raison de s'accrocher
aux majorité de non hélas est ce qu on
est soulagés par l'élection de joe biden
là encore sur twitter c'est une majorité
de non de son côté
en tout cas de son côté joe biden lui
n'en a cure il l'a annoncé la mise en
place d'une cellule de crise antique le
vide
c'était juste avant l'annoncé par fire
que 80 à 4 à 90% de chance la firme
américaine affirme avoir son vaccin ça
risque d'être donc un très joli match à
suivre entre chinois américains et
russes peut-être français on verra ça
éventuellement avec vous nicolas de son
côté donald trump lui a salué cette
découverte à la saluer les performances
de la bourse de new york
al'annonce de 7,2 cette information et
il refuse toujours de reconnaître sa
défaite
on va voir le tweet qu'il a
fait cette nuit depuis quand les médias
de masse 10 qui sera notre prochain
président nous avons tous beaucoup
appris au cours des deux dernières
semaines sur ce twitt un commentaire
nicholas le commentaire il est très
rapide c'est à dire que aux états unis
la tradition c'est que ce sont les
grands médias qui effectivement annonce
quand ils estiment le vainqueur mais
al'inverse ce ne sont pas les médias qui
font l'élection
ce ne sont d'ailleurs pas les juges
n'ont plus ce sont les électeurs
hélas les électeurs ont très clairement
tranché puisque finalement le ticket by
donne kamala harris
l'élection a eu une participation
considérable
c'est le ticket président vice président
qui aura le plus de voix dans l'histoire
des etats unis le nombre de l'écart de
grands électeurs et très fort y compris
en termes d'état la chose ne se discute
pas donc ce qu'on voit en revanche mais
ça c'est une question qui s'adresse à
alexandre c'est que les pseudo populiste
qui sont soit disant les héros de la
souveraineté populaire c'est les héros
de la souveraineté populaire tant qu'il
gagne et des grès dès lors qu'ils
perdent
eh bien ils refusent le résultat il
refuse le résultat du vote donc mais ça
les dernières choses ensuite évidemment
la défaite de trump n'est pas la défaite
le populisme a perdu une bataille mais
pas la guerre et par ailleurs les causes
profondes qui ont fait que trump est
arrivé au pouvoir ne sont pas réglés
mais ça sera maintenant le problème de
bild
alors on va justement avoir la réponse
de
alexandre puisque vous l'avez défier
tout de suite sur le fait que les
populistes refuse de reconnaître leur
leur défaite est peut-être déjà un
commentaire par rapport à ce que disait
nicolas cette tradition aux états unis
sont les médias qui annoncent qui est le
président élu donc s'en remet pas en
cause du tout la légitimité de l'annonce
alors je pense que je suis pas du tout
choquée qu'ils annoncent le candidat
d'autant plus que ça à l'air le
vainqueur le vainqueur d'autant plus que
ça à l'air net j'étais plus choqués
lorsqu'ils sont sur est au préalable les
discours de donald trump ne trouve que
le quatrième pouvoir
et parfois le pouvoir tout court je dis
là on a connu une époque où ce sont les
chefs d'état qui sont sûrs et les médias
aujourd'hui ce sont les médias qui sont
sur les chefs d'état ça doit quand même
nous faire réfléchir
ensuite je note que dans le concept et
al gore george bush
il ya une vingtaine d'années al gore
contestait les résultats les médias ont
attendu 45 jours avant d'annoncer le
vainqueur certes c'était plus serré sans
doute qu'aujourd'hui pour répondre à
nicolas baverez je fais partie de ceux
qui auraient aimé que que donald trump
et la décence commune finalement de
reconnaître sa défaite d'autant plus que
je pense que cette contestation risque
de jeter un voile sur son héritage et
sur son bilan politique qui sera sans
doute réévalué à l'avenir mais je note
par ailleurs
finalement il renvoie la monnaie de sa
pièce ou parti démocrate et aux médias
pour le coup car la majorité des merdias
qui jusqu'au bout avait refusé de
reconnaître sa légitimité de président
souvenez vous on l'avait accusé d'avoir
été élu grâce aux hackers russes et les
démocrates ont été jusqu'à mettre une
procédure d'impeachment contre lui a
déclenché de procédure de destitution
donc finalement c'est un peu manichéen
de dire il ya les méchants populis qui
n'acceptent pas le jeu de la démocratie
il ya les gentils
l'establishment qui respecte les règles
démocratiques je crois que s'il ya
effectivement un malaise dans la
démocratie aussi bien aux états unis que
dans toutes les démocraties occidentales
mais donald trump nom n'est que le
symptôme est la cause profonde et vous
l'avez ski et ses vient d'ailleurs vient
justement de feu de médias qui sont de
plus en plus pas du tout en partout on
l'a vu pendant quatre ans du mandat de
donald trump ça vient du front du fait
que les experts prennent de plus en plus
de place ça vient du fait que les
marchés prennent de la place par rapport
à la souveraineté populaire je pense que
c'est tout ça et finalement là dedans la
personnalité un peu décoiffantes de
donald trump n'a fait qu'aggraver les
choses mais c'est plus un symptôme
qu'une cause alors avant d'avoir votre
réponse nicolas je voudrais pour
alimenter le débat
confiez donné ces deux éléments d'abord
que sur le web dans les sondages dans la
plupart des réactions dans le monde en
général et en france en particulier
c'est le soulagement qui domine
et c'est notamment le cas ce matin dans
la classe politique française avait que
deux personnes que a priori tout oppose
d'un côté le ministre de l'agriculture
julien de normandie et le député la
france a soumises du nord adrien à 4 nas
tous les deux soulagés voilà ce que une
administration d'arrivée l'avènement
d'une administration baydan peu selon le
changer très concrètement c'est
d'apaiser la discussion vous savez que
entre les états unis et l'europe
il ya une sorte de guerre commerciale
qui s'est instaurée je pense notamment à
tous les viticulteurs trump avait mis en
une taxe en place qui s'appelle la taxe
se trompent qui faisait que toute
bouteille de vin arrivant sur le
territoire américain et aient accès à 25
% avec d'énormes conséquences évidemment
pour nos producteurs de vin j'ose
espérer que l'arrivée de
l'administration byden va pouvoir
changer le climat de ces discussions est
arrivé à trouver un accord très
rapidement pour mettre fin par exemple à
cette taxe non je suis assez satisfait
que nous puissions être sans doute
débarrassé des outrances de donald trump
il ya un certain nombre de choses sur
lesquelles je suis attentiste j'ai vu
que joe biden avait annoncé le retour
des états unis d'amérique dans le cadre
des accords de paris sur le climat je
pense que ce serait un bon point en
effet s'il le faisait ensuite je pense
que finalement quelle que soit l'issue
et a priori donc l'élection de joe biden
qui est maintenant confirmé je crois que
l'important pour la france et y compris
pour la paix dans le monde céda d'être
une puissance indépendante
un commentaire sur ce que dit justement
un cadenas
en fait c'est assez c'est assez juste et
à dire que ce qui ce qui se passe c'est
que on voit poindre une espèce
d'illusion que la victoire de bayonne
nous ramènerait l'amérique de 45
et ça c'est absolument faux donc
joe biden comme l'a dit barack obama il
va devoir affronter la pire situation
qu'a connue sans doute un président des
états unis il a la crise sanitaire
l'épidémie avec le nombre record de
morts
il a une récession historique il ya une
nation profondément désuni polarisée il
a un déficit de 16 % du pib' une dette à
100% du pib
même si tout le monde considère que ce
n'est pas un problème mais s'en est
quand même il à la compétition avec la
chine
il va devoir affronter tous a
vraisemblablement sans majorité au
congrès puisque on va voir les élections
de georgi mais vraisemblablement ce qui
peut en même temps être une chance parce
que ça obligera à passer des compromis
avec les républicains donc conclusion de
ça la priorité ça va être l'agenda
intérieur sur l'extérieur il n'ya pas
d'illusions à voir le tournant
protectionnistes il ne va pas être remis
en cause le repli des états unis et
d'europe et du moyen-orient et le pivot
vers l'asie qui était déjà la stratégie
d'obama
ça va continuer mais c'est vrai que le
climat va changer il y aura plus de
respect d'écouté des alliés et il y à
aussi vis-à-vis de du système
multilatéral sur le on a parlé de la
cour de paris c'est vrai il ya également
l'om est sous les états unis vont
revenir donc sa conclusion pratique de
ça c'est vrai que de ce point de vue là
adrien cap nasa raison c'est que pour
les français comme pour les européens ça
veut dire qu'il faut il ne faut pas être
dans l'attentisme
il faut proposer un agenda commercial un
agenda sur le numérique
un agenda sur le stratégique aux équipes
et un agenda sur le climat aux équipes
de joe biden on est d'accord sur
l'international c'est là où je disais
que le bilan ne trompe pas les intérêts
réévalué alors on peut le regretter ou
pas mais je crois que le
l'inflexion le tournant protectionnistes
donald trump effectivement va continuer
parce que il a convaincu tout simplement
une majorité d'américains que c'était
nécessaire notamment en termes de
désindustrialisation et de maîtrise
stratégique je crois pas la crise du
coronavirus a donné raison à donald
trump là dessus et je crois qu'il ya une
prise de conscience populaire que le
verrier et des élites aussi il faut le
dire que le véritable adversaire des
états unis était la chine donc et
peut-être de l'occident aujourd'hui
donc là je là je suis d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit nicolas baverez
maintenant qu'elle est je suis d'accord
aussi que son grand défi va être sur le
plan intérieur alors on peut être
espérer effectivement qu'il a réussit là
où a très clairement échoué donald trump
et à réconcilier les deux amériques
donald trump a parlé à sa base pendant
quatre ans il n'a pas tendu la main à
l'autre amérique il avait été aidé en
cela quand même par le le parti
démocrate qui s'est effectivement
radicaliser comme je les ai expliqué qui
a refusé de reconnaître sa légitimité
qu'ils étaient pris en otage par une
minorité qui voulaient aller toujours
plus loin dans une forme de
déconstruction de multiculturalisme de
politiques d identité donc on peut
espérer que qu'abidal réussi j'ai des
doutes il se définit lui-même comme
comme progressiste
on voit que le progrès c'est
généralement c'est plus d'impôts plus de
technocratie plus de politiquement
correct plus d'immigration et donc je
pense que pour convaincre cette amérique
qui est en rébellion
il faudra pas simplement des mots un
style plus compassé que celui de donald
trump qu'il faudra des actes sur ce que
ce dont je parlais immigration
politiquement correct protectionnisme
économique etc
je salue les internautes du figaro qui
nous rejoignent depuis le début qui
commente ce que vous dites c'est qu'ils
commentent également la situation je
salue seach marcus guy nicolle notamment
qui nous ont rejoints dès le début
christophe aussi alors sur twitter même
on avait déjà des commentaires et des
réponses
je vous rappelle la question que l'on
pose est est ce que vous êtes
êtes vous soulagé par la proclamation de
joe biden comme président des états unis
vous êtes une majorité une petite
majorité à répondre non 54 % comme jf on
pourrait être assurée s'il était
effectivement élu ce n'est pas encore le
cas officiellement mais comme l'a
rappelé nicolas baverez l'aise aux etats
unis c'est traditionnellement les médias
qui annoncent en premier qui est
officiellement et lui ai dit nous dit
baye donne un comportement rassurant
pour tout le peuple américain il cherche
union de son pays
il veut peut véritablement réussir à
apaiser les nombreuses tensions qui
subsistent alors c'était ça ce dont
doutent et alexandre est ce que vous
vous pensez bien que là qu'il peut
réaliser ces tensions passées réussir
c'est évidemment de temps en temps c'est
un président de transition il l'a dit
lui même à la ch'ti là il ne fera qu'un
mandat et s'étend modérée ce qui est
intéressant dans cette élection c'est
que les extrémistes des deux camps ont
été défaits en réalité donc trump a été
lui-même un d'extrémistes mais les
extrémistes du côté démocrate ont été
mis de côté justement pour avoir une
candidature by donne ce candidat qui est
un candidat par défaut il sera peut-être
l'homme de la situation c'est déjà
arrivé dans l'histoire des états unis
rappelez-vous truman qui après le
roosevelt flamboyant et est considéré
comme un homme de second plan
truman a été bien meilleur dans la
guerre froide que laura était roosevelt
qui était extrêmement complaisant
vis-à-vis de de staline et donc bye
donne précisément parce que c'est un mot
dirai pas ce que c'est un homme qui a
passé 50 ans de sa vie au sénat a
négocié avec les républicains parce
qu'il est apprécié par beaucoup des
leaders républicains
en tout cas il a une chance de pouvoir
réconcilier les états unis finalement
aujourd'hui dans l'univers dans cette
classe politique américaine c'est sans
doute le s'il y en a un qui peut y
arriver c'est lui mais
on verra comment les choses se déroulent
pas ce que vous partagez cette optimise
etc sans nom mais il faut effectivement
pas le sous-estimer il a il a remporté
l'élection ce qui n'était pas facile
face à donald rome tout le monde disait
sli claude jottrand pl le caricatural
moi j'ai toujours de lancer hormis les
geôles endormi bonjour l'endormi assez
quand même réveillé a été suffisamment
relayée on avait même pensé à mettre
michelle obama à sa place pour être sûrs
que parce qu'il est on était sûrs qu'ils
financent et wake up to n'ont finalement
je pense que en tout cas j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il était meilleur candidat que
qu'hillary clinton parce qu'il allait
plus de pâte humaine et il était moins
caricatural dans l'incarnation d'une
morgue démocrate dans une sorte de
progressisme en limousine comme on dit
là bas comme on dirait chez nous la
gauche caviar donc il était moins
caricatural là dessus et je pense que
d'ailleurs il a fait des scores pas
mauvais dans les états de la rose bêtes
là où tout s'est joué et que le parti
démocrate avait avait perdu donnait pas
gagné
donc non il n'a pas gagné la l'ohio et
je pense que je les dis aussi je les ai
écrites le phénomène 30 sera durable
humain notamment chez les classes
populaires américaines mais voilà on
peut ne peut lui donner le bénéfice du
doute en début de mandat après moi ce
qui me chagrine de mots quand même parce
que j'ai écouté son discours de réduire
de la réconciliation il expliqué qu'il
allait racheter l'âme de l'amérique
donc là encore l'impression qu'on va
avoir beaucoup de bons sentiments de
politiquement correct est ce que joe
biden peut vraiment donner des leçons de
morale à donald trump je rappelle qu' il
est poursuivi pour viol qu'il est
surnommé par certaines militante
démocrate tonton le perverse donc donner
des morales sur le côté féministe comme
ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon
surtout quand on est en otage d'une
d'une frange radicale qui pourra lui
poser beaucoup de problèmes et ensuite
sur le racisme
rappelons ce qu'ils disaient de bahia
barack obama cet afro-américain qui
s'exprime bien et qui est propre sur lui
donc je il faut toujours se méfier des
gens qui donnent des leçons de morale
steria donald trump avait un style
outrancier qu'on pouvait être déplorés
ça veut pas dire que moralement
joe biden
ce sera forcément au dessus après moi
c'est pas forcément ce que j'attends
d'un président j'attends surtout de
l'efficacité
si tu le dis apparemment il ya pas mal
de recours en cour par trump on ferait
bien d'attendre que ça se termine avant
d'encenser bailon certains lé recours ou
est-ce qu'on en est est ce qu'il ya des
chances pour autres un peuple que ça
aboutisse à quelque chose selon vous
nicolas alors les recours sont toujours
possibles et là il faut être clair que
trump face des recours c'est son droit
le plus strict les etats-unis sont un
état de droit tout candidat battu peut
faire des recours
je crois pas qu'ils vont prospérer
beaucoup parce que l'écart est quand
même très impressionnant et par ailleurs
le fait que trump est d'emblée dit que
attaquer partout c'est aussi pour ça que
le dépouillement après du temps c'est
parce qu'on n'a jamais fait autant
attention aux opérations de
dépouillement
donc je crois que le résultat sera très
difficile à contester et je pense pas
que la cour suprême va se précipiter
pour traiter de
de ce problème ce qui est préoccupant
donc chez trump en tout cas c'est pas la
contestation elle est ouverte à tous les
candidats ce qui est très inquiétant
c'est le fait qu'ils contestent le
principe même de l'élection est donc là
c'est ce que disent et c'est là où on
voit que le le populisme n'est pas pour
la souveraineté en tout cas trump très
clairement il a mis en cause le
processus électoral lui même il a mis en
cause les institutions
donc c'est un homme qui n'est pas un
démocrate c'est ça et et les appels
implicites à la violence sont
inadmissibles
donc pour l'instant heureusement on a
pas eu d'incident mais c'est clair que
ça on est en dehors du jeu démocratique
un mot encore on va conclure moi j'ai
dit ce que j'avais à dire au début je
crois qu'on joue à se faire peur être
mon diabolise donald trump les
démocrates en d'autres temps d'autres
circonstances il ya quatre ans avec
donald trump ont fait les choses sans
doute avec des formes plus
institutionnelle je vous la corde mais
sur le fond ce n'était pas très
différent je veux croire à une accalmie
détention de différence sur youtube
avec cette victoire mais je ne suis pas
naïve sur les rapports de force qui
persisteront entre l'europe et des états
unis et nos interlocuteurs nos invités
non plus cher florence je ne suis
soulagé que du départ de trump de la
maison blanche nous dit nicole cela ne
veut pas dire que biden n'a pas cette
heure également et c'était également le
point de vue d'alexandre de deux vecchio
etes-vous justement soulagés par
élection de joe biden à la maison
blanche
eh bien vous campez sur l'opposition et
vous avez été très nombreux à répondre
sur twitter et à nous répondre non à 54%
il y à une autre question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter cécile faut ressusciter
le gaullisme j'ai une douleur dans l'eau
c'était sont parmi les derniers mots
prononcés par charles de gaulle avant de
s'éteindre le 9 novembre 1970
on a vu aujourd'hui
un hommage comme chaque année
colombey-les-deux-églises pardon hommage
restreint on va en voir quelques images
pour cause d'épidémie comme chaque année
les républicains rendre hommage au
fondateur de la vème république voici
par exemple la péroraison de geoffroy
didier ce matin
50 ans après sa mort charles de gaulle
le général de gaulle est une leçon de
politique permanente pour nous tous
parce qu'il a eu cet esprit de
résistance
il est allé lui seul raviver la flamme
de la france durant la seconde guerre
mondiale et puis cet esprit
d'indépendance indépendance de la france
indépendance stratégique par rapport à
la concurrence mondiale la concurrence
effrénée que nous subissons mais le
général de gaulle n'est pas seulement
une leçon de politique il doit aussi
être une leçon de modestie parce que
tout le monde s'en réclament
non mais personne je dis bien personne
ne lui arrive aujourd'hui à la cheville
ouais alex enjouaillez serait en
entendant geoffroy didier c'est parce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui personne
ne lui arrive à la cheville et donc il
est possible de ressusciter le gaullisme
main droite je frappe et y est je pense
à raison de faire preuve de modestie je
note surtout que tout le monde est
gaulliste aujourd'hui ça veut surtout
dire que plus personne ne l'est à mon
sens à droite et à gauche fait longtemps
que il on voit l'ami les dernière
pelletée de terre sur le cercueil ce
qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy notamment
sortant de l'otan je pense qu'il ya un
principe fondamental ou en y revenons
pas donc il ya real était sortie du
commandement du commandement intégré de
l'otan pour être pour être exact
non mais il ya un principe il ya un
principe chez le général de gaulle que
que beaucoup ont oublié c'est celui de
la souveraineté et disait que système
qui consistera
à transmettre notre souveraineté pardon
à des aréopages internationaux seraient
incompatibles avec les droits et les
devoirs de la république je pense que
tout est dit je pense que le général de
gaulle ne partagerait pas la vision
européenne qui a été défendue par la
droite et la gauche et ces quarante
dernières années
nicolas je me suis amusé à refléter cet
excellent livre qui s'appelle les
grandes figures de la droite de la
révolution française aux jo et je vois
que votre description d'une figure de la
droite n'est pas celle du général de
gaulle elle vient juste après celle de
raymond aron
c'était ce que le libéral tocqueville
lien que vous êtes rendrai comme hommage
au général de gaulle est ce que vous
vous rendriez l'hommage qu'a rendu
geoffroy didier je pense que le
l'hommage rendu par geoffroy didier
manque une partie de l'essentiel ce qui
est vrai c'est que le général de gaulle
à une c'est l'homme clé du xxème siècle
pour la france avec clemenceau c'est
celui qui a sauvé l'honneur de la france
en 1940 c'est celui qui a quand même
sauvé deux fois la république
il a rétabli une première fois en 44-45
ensuite il l'a rétabli une seconde fois
en 1958 il a établi un régime qui va
sans doute battre des records de
longévité et je trouve que mes que le
vrai héritage jédir il est plutôt
intellectuelle et morale c'est à dire
d'un côté cette idée singulière cette
certaine idée de la france
mais surtout et c'est pour ça que on
peut pas ressuscité ni drôle ni le
gaullisme le dernier gaulliste a été
philippe séguin et malheureusement il
est mort
l'équation oui mais c'est pas pour ça
que je pense c'est qu'il ya très bien
voilà
mais je pense que c'est la réalité que
d'ailleurs ça expliquait en partie les
tensions avec jacques chirac
mais ce qui est important chez le
général de gaulle aujourd'hui c'est sa
conception de l'histoire et c'est pour
ça que le gaullisme ne peut pas
ressuscité parce que beaucoup veulent le
prendre comme une espèce de doctrine
figé or depuis le début le génie de
gaulle c'est la compréhension l'histoire
rappelez vous son premier livre de
l'armée de métier c'est la mécanique de
choc et de vitesse et ce qui est
incroyable c'est que pour le coup le
gaullisme a jamais été plus actuelle
parce que on est dans un monde de choc
et de vitesse mais le régime qu'il a
fondé lui au départ la vème république
où l'état était censé être le garant de
la nation face aux secousses et ooshop
de l'histoire cet état aujourd'hui il
est devenu un risque supplémentaire
parce que le choc et la vitesse on l'a
vu avec l'épidémie on le voit avec
l'économie
c'est un état qui est obèse surendettés
impuissant et qui est incapable de
répondre aujourd'hui aux défis du 21e
siècle donc cet état dont de gaulle
avait voulu faire le garant de la nation
c'est aujourd'hui retournée contre
contre contre la nation mais ça c'est
pas la faute du général de gaulle c'est
la faute de ses successeurs
donc il faut pas ressuscité si je suis
le gaullisme dans ce sens là il faut
retrouver l'esprit du gaullisme parce
que cette conception de l'histoire ça
celle-là elle reste tout à fait sûr
l'état je vous revois mais est-ce qu'il
faut jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
est ce que c'est parce que ses
successeurs n'ont pas été digne non pas
qu on est passé d'une technocratie de
grand commis de l'état qui qui qui
servait la nation à une technocratie qui
parfois semblé se reproduire elle même
est ce que c'est pour autant de pauvres
au jarret de veau rask pour vincent
josse bt est ce qu'il faut jeter l'état
avec jefferson largement je suis pas
personne ne propose de jeter l'état
simplement il faut remettre l'état là où
il doit être dans les missions
régaliennes
la délinquance et à linverse il faut
arrêter que les tables prétendent tout
faire a récemment l'état elle a expliqué
dans un supermarché quels sont les biens
essentiels qu'on peut vendre et qu'elle
soutient donnée essentielle qu'on ne
peut pas vendre un pyjama ou un enfant
de moins de deux ans et fait le buzz et
l'alcool aurait dit les vo vous allez y
aurait eu bien raison vous êtes
d'haguenau est d'accord et la politique
de la france ne se fait pas à la
corbeille as un peu moins d'une un peu
plus d'une mais il ya un point qui
m'inquiète je pense vous n'êtes pas
d'accord c'est sur le sur le plan
justement de la politique étrangère sur
le corps et santé de l'autisme nicolas
n'a pas n'a pas répondu on a un état qui
avait effectivement aux belles mais
surtout qui n'est plus sourd je vous
répondre de manière très pratique et
historique
quand le général de gaulle revient vous
pouvoir en 58
on vient y lire le traité de rome en 57
tout le monde est certain que de gaulle
va instantanément arrêté qu'est ce que
dit de gaulle il dit on va certainement
pas arrêté parce qu'il sait que c'est
une idée qui est très intelligente midi
nous allons faire l'europe mais nous la
ferons debout et je rappelle que de
gaulle a avancé le calendrier du marché
comment c'est aller beaucoup plus vite
et c'est lui qu'il a accéléré et donc
évidemment et donc et chez de gaulle
c'est de gaulle qui lance l'idée d'une
europe politique et cette europe
politique
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui donc dont vous êtes pour
l'europe du plan fouchet on est d'accord
puisque il accepte assez eux mais
derrière d'abord une refuse l'entrée de
la grande-bretagne
dans l'union européenne et ensuite on
propose il propose un plan fouchet c'est
assez visionneur puisqu'ils ont ressorti
finalement à voir donc très visuel et
ensuite ils proposent un flop foucher
qui est une europe de la coopération
entre les nations ont d'ailleurs il ne
compte pas jean monnet et déjà retrouver
une phrase il n'ya pas longtemps dans
ses mémoires il dit que ce qui est les
empereurs qui ont voulu enfin il parle
de césar il parle de pas le même
d'hitler et c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on
a voulu faire une europe intégrée
ça s'est mal terminée de gaulle c'est le
sens des réalités europe l intelligence
policier ijaz une europe cela me
rappelle que de gaulle y vit dans le
monde de la guerre froide et que
d'ailleurs il a eu tout en ouvrant sur
la détente il est très ferme vis-à-vis
du le monde du 21e siècle n'est pas le
monde du 20e siècle et de gaulle sera le
premier à dire que les formules que lui
a trouvé deux sont certainement pas
celles qui doivent être aujourd'hui
déployés mais l'indépendance nationale
et la certaine idée de la france ça ça
doit subsister sur la détente je vais
être obligé d'appuyer dessus parce que
justement c'est le temps imparti qui est
terminée puisqu'on par le général de
gaulle
ce sera un autre match aussi qu'on
rendra à notre ami trop tôt disparu
denis tillinac qui avait écrit ce très
beau dictionnaire amoureux du général de
gaulle alors qu'on ait connu de gaulle
ou pas con quoi qu'on pense du général
de gaulle et ben c'est à dire parce que
ça donne le plaisir également de lire et
de relire denis tillinac dictionnaire
amoureux du général et de gaulle et 7
directionnelle amoureux du général tout
court et d'ailleurs et c'est aux
éditions plon
faut-il ressusciter le gaullisme
cinquante ans après la mort de charles
de gaulle c'était la question que vous
posez sur twitter et vous êtes plutôt
nostalgique dans les réponses que vous
faites pas été là aussi assez nombreux 5
58%
à répondre oui vous avez été nombreux à
répondre on citera notamment nicole on
ne peut pas ressusciter le gaullisme car
de gaulle est unique mais il faudrait
enfin trouvé quelqu'un de la même trempe
que lui c'est dommage ça on n'est pas
revenu justement sur la notion d'homme
providentiel d'un bout de femme
providentielle tout le monde se
revendique du gaullisme estime babineau
aujourd'hui c'est symptomatique de la
pauvreté de l'offre politique en france
et nathan de gaulle a fait progresser la
construction européenne mais il
n'accepterait jamais de se mettre à plat
ventre devant l'union européenne comme
la france le fait aujourd'hui
et bien il y a de quoi avoir matière un
nouveau débat dans vos commentaires et
je vous propose qu'on les tienne dans
les prochains jours on vous donne en
tout cas rendez vous demain même heure
même endroit sans avoir oublié de
signaler les deux ouvrages qu'il faut
absolument lire en plus du dictionnaire
amoureux du général l'alertent et
démocratique ça c'est le livre le
dernier livre de nicolas baverez c'est
aux éditions de l'observatoire et le
recomposition les nouveaux mondes
populiste c'est aux éditions du cerf et
c'est d'alexandre ii vecchio
dans les deux cas il faut le lire et on
se retrouve très vite sur figaro l'âge
on annonce qu'à 18h30 jérôme c'est le
monde doit tenir un point presse
on va le suivre en direct sur figure en
live
[Musique]